we need to take a closer look at the
true origins of mankind and the roots of
ancient human civilization and there is
no better place to start
then the earliest known or I should say
documented civilization which is the
Sumerians of ancient Mesopotamia dating
back 6,000 years and they seem to
literally show us multiple individuals
flying down and being greeted by those
here on earth as well as possible
knowledge of the cosmos including the
planets in our very own solar system
and in this video I'm going to connect
the dots on several key details
involving the Sumerians the Greek gods
and the myths and legends of so many
civilizations cultures and religions
that are shared across multiple
continents from around the world now let
me first mention that human civilization
does date back much earlier than the
Sumerians of 6,000 years ago for example
like I've discussed in other videos
gobekli tepe in turkey is dated to be at
least 12,000 years old with us double
the age of the Sumerians and this site
is still a mystery
another example involves the rain water
erosion around the limestone bedrock
enclosure of the Great Sphinx of Giza
Egypt which states it to be at least
double the age of what we were taught in
school unlikely to be tens of thousands
of years older which of course raises
many questions you may also recall
articles from the recent skeletal
discovery that dates modern humans to be
closer to three hundred and fifty
thousand years old or one hundred and
seventy-five thousand years older than
previously thought yet despite us modern
humans existing for more than three
hundred thousand years we know so little
about our history from even 6000 years
ago with the Sumerians or even four
thousand years ago with the ancient
Egyptians or the ancient Greeks yet we
have multiple shared myths and legends
involving the story of creation
involving beings coming here and
creating modern man as well as legends
about humans living to be hundreds and
even thousands of years in age and I'll
be discussing more details on that in
just a moment but it's important to keep
in mind that over long periods of time
history turns into legend and legend
turns into myth but at their root myths
and legends have some sort of truth
within them whatever that may be
and the telephone game is a great
analogy that shows how easily and
quickly indirect communication can be
corrupted and it cannot be overstated
how significant this is in regards to
what we know about history and how it's
virtually impossible for truth to not be
lost through time and translation so let
me discuss one of the myths that are
shared by more than 500 civilizations
cultures and religions from around the
world including the Sumerians and that
is the myth of a global flood and this
map is not exactly scientific it's
something I made to show how widespread
this legend actually is and most of
these dots represent multiple
civilizations or cultures but what's
been commonly referred to as a myth is
now considered scientific fact at least
to some degree and I'll give more
details on that for those who are not
familiar with this information but
thanks to modern science and data taken
from ice core samples from both
Greenland and Antarctica we have
identified evidence that the Earth's
global sea levels have increased by more
than 400 feet since the height of the
last ice age and of course much of that
occurred over a period of thousands of
years but some of it happened in an
incredibly short period of time as the
evidence indicates sudden and rapid sea
level change perhaps even as much as 30
feet in a 24-hour period
closer to 12,000 years ago and I
recommend that you research the Younger
Dryas impact hypothesis for details on
this evidence which is actually
overwhelming and completely fascinating
and of course I've mentioned these
details in other videos but it has to be
repeated as it demonstrates that there
is actual physical scientific evidence
to back up something that was once
considered a myth and like I mentioned
with the telephone game analogy earlier
the facts get altered over time and I
think that the biblical story of stating
that every mountain on earth was covered
in water as a result of 40 days and
nights of rainfall well to say that
every mountain was under water isn't
accurate
but perhaps vast areas and regions were
covered in water but the story was
passed down for more than five thousand
years before the Sumerians actually
wrote about it on clay tablets so my
next point of discussion are legends of
extreme longevity which is something
shared by the Sumerians as well as
multiple other civilizations and
religions from across the world which is
that people once lived to be several
hundred years
and even in some cases thousands of
years in age now this is notably
discussed in the Bible but it's also
shared in Islam Hinduism Dharma or
Jainism they all share legends of people
living to be several hundred years in
age and even thousands of years in age
but it's not just religions specific
regions of the world also shared this
legend as well for example Vietnam
ancient Persia and other places all
discussed these legends now right off
the bat some will say that the story
from the Bible of Noah living to be 950
years old must be referring to months
because 950 months equates to 79 years
in age of when he would have died so
that of course makes far more sense but
if that's the case then what about those
that live to only be a hundred something
months in age which would put nearly
half the biblical list at 12 years old
or younger and even as young as 9 years
old when he died and somehow had done so
much in their lives as told in the
stories so that doesn't seem to make
sense but neither does living to be 950
years old and like I mentioned the
Sumerians also share this legend of
extreme longevity they documented the
pre diluvian god king list which by the
way pre diluvian means pre flood and
details that 10 Sumerian Kings lived to
be tens of thousands of years old
obviously that's a ridiculously long
period of time but what's to say that
there isn't some truth to it that
perhaps at one point in the distant past
people live to be significantly older
than we do today I mean we're already
heading in that direction now aren't we
look at how we've made massive leaps in
stem cell research which is looking to
be a complete game-changer in modern
medicine stem-cell treatment has helped
athletes with various injuries and
they're calling it a possible
breakthrough or game-changer for people
with multiple cirrhosis another example
is how recently two people had their
eyesight restored from stem cells
treatment and even early research has
shown that stem cell treatment has
countered Alzheimer's development and
this is 2018 research by the way we're
also growing new organs on our bodies
and even on the bodies of other animals
such as mice and pigs which is amazing
and I mean we are basically already
living in a science fiction world and we
don't really seem to reflect on it much
at the pace we're going it won't be long
for we were replacing our own organs for
new ones and using stem cell treatments
to treat our brains when they start to
slow from Alzheimer's or dementia just
think about how amazing these things are
and this is just the beginning it won't
be long before the human lifespan is
increased significantly but if there is
some truth to humans once living extreme
lifespans
when there need to be some evidence that
they were advanced well what most people
don't know is that there is existing
evidence that ancient humans were once
significantly more advanced than we were
ever taught in school take the Great
Pyramid of Giza Egypt as an example
whoever built it seemed to know the
dimensions of the earth and I've
discussed this in other videos as well
but the evidence is remarkably
compelling the numbers are there and
math doesn't lie for more specific
details on this I highly recommend that
you look into the work of Randall
Carlson he discusses this in great
detail and I'll include links to his
YouTube and website in the description
of this video also with the Great
Pyramid of Giza is proximity to the
geographical center of the Earth's
landmass this amazing detail is unknown
to most people and no I do not think
that this is just a coincidence but more
than that it's really important to
understand that we also do not know what
the original purpose was for the
pyramids yes we were taught in school
that they were tombs but there is
virtually zero evidence of any kind to
even suggest that they were built for
the purpose of being a tomb take it upon
yourself to research the Great Pyramid
and alternative theories for its purpose
but clearly it was something highly
sophisticated and technological and when
you study the specifics of it
particularly the internal structure it
becomes clear that we do not know what
we're looking at and actually this
reminds me of a quote from the beginning
of the Lord of the Rings movie trilogy
and I'm a total nerd by the way thus the
third age of middle-earth began history
became legend legend became myth and
some things that should not have been
forgotten were lost and this quote is
very fitting for us and the mystery of
lost ancient human civilization so
moving along the next point I want to
discuss are the myths and legends of
creation and this is of course found in
the most common religions around the
world with legends of angels demons sky
gods all coming here in some way to
create modern man this legend is shared
by the Sumerians as well and there are
in fact
seven tablets which discuss the story of
creation so besides the Sumerian solar
system tablet which may indicate
advanced knowledge of the solar system
and the planets in it there's also a
tablet appearing to show three
individuals flying down to earth and
being greeted I mean what exactly is
this depicting and there are more than
one tablet showing miss just look at
these other two tablets and think for
yourself what were they trying to tell
us you know if you replace words like
angels demons or sky gods with the word
alien and most of the world's religions
it would all start to make far more
sense women even similar stories are
shared by the Hopi Indians of North
America and the Aborigines of Australia
which basically tell the same story
except that they states that beings came
from underground rather than above but
just look at the certain examples of
Hopi and Aboriginal wall art pretty
eerie depictions and it's fascinating
when you pair it with this quote we do
not walk alone Great Beings walked
beside us know this and be grateful this
brings me to the Dead Sea Scrolls which
were hidden and preserved in caves on
the side of cliffs near the Dead Sea one
of the things they found was the book of
the Watchers within the Book of Enoch
the Watchers how creepy is that nobody
knows who wrote them but what I find
particularly interesting is that whoever
it was went to an incredible extent to
hide and preserve this information
included in the book of the Watchers
which was hidden in a cave on the side
of a cliff buried in sealed jars hidden
for thousands of years you know this
reminds me of the Nazca lines in Peru
with the waving astronaut which is
massive and mostly appreciated from the
air because it's on the side of a
mountain and there are also other
depictions with some refer to as runways
now this is a mystery they don't know
who made this or when so in regards to
creation if beings did come here from
elsewhere to create modern man what they
need to have knowledge of DNA and our
genetics in order to do something like
that which by the way is basically what
we're already doing now I mean I shared
earlier examples of how we're growing
organs and we've also cloned more than
20 species of animal and this gets me
thinking what if the famous llama
so the winged Bulls found in the ancient
Samaria region what if they are actually
showing us what someone did now of
course that sounds a bit ridiculous but
if it were possible to genetically put
your head onto the body of a bull or
perhaps maybe a horse's body and some
wings onto it for show
without a doubt I can see various world
leaders jumping on that crap in a
heartbeat to do it and now that's just a
fun thought but of course the mainstream
explanation for the winged Bulls is that
they're simply mythological deities but
it's a curious topic as they made so
many of these with such high precision
in fact they made hundreds of them but
it's worth mentioning just how many
Sumerian tablets depict humans with
wings and in these same tablets there
are other individuals without wings
could this be symbolic of say someone or
those that flew here in some way or
could it simply just depict Kings who
were looked at as royalty or gobbly if
there ever was any type of genetic
modification they would certainly need
to have knowledge of DNA like I
mentioned earlier and there is some
evidence to indicate that the ancients
were aware of DNA and the double helix
and also commonly referred to as the
caduceus this also relates to various
legends of the first people including
the story of Adam and Eve and other
legends from around the world and the
tree of knowledge and life and could
this story be based from the Sumerians
because they have tablets that seem to
depict something very similar but what
I'm most curious about is the missing
skeletal link in the evolution of modern
humans now real quick I am NOT denying
evolution there is without a doubt
evidence of this with in the fossil
record among primates and in fact
hundreds of other species found
throughout nature in fact we even see
evidence of evolution within language
within culture within technology even if
we study the cosmos we see that
everything is constantly moving even at
the atomic level atoms as an example are
constantly vibrating they are never
constant so perhaps it's a universal law
that everything is always in a state of
change but we are discussing modern
humans and the best example they have of
physical scientific evidence to support
the theory of evolution for modern
humans it's actually surprising just how
weak it really is and this refers to a
2015 discovery which they consider to be
the best example of a missing link
skeleton but it's only five feet tall
they estimated that
800 pounds the brain was get this the
size of an orange the fingers even
arched in the opposite direction of
humans and arts in the direction of
chimps and apes and the feet were quote
similar to ours I mean clearly there is
a missing chapter in the development of
modern-day humans because how is it that
we have so many dinosaur bones from what
they say are from 65 million years ago
and here we are in 2018 and we have
essentially zero skeletons that show or
justify the bridge of evolution to
modern humans so why the sudden jump why
is there such a mystery involving the
massive change in the size of the brain
and the cranial cavity in modern humans
something doesn't add up now some of
theorized as a possible explanation for
the missing skeletal link of modern
humans is that well we're looking for
something that's not supposed to be
there anyways that maybe it's related to
the various interbreeding or intermixing
of various species of Homo sapiens the
different branches of them from long ago
and that perhaps that just isn't
supposed to be the skeleton that we're
looking for but ultimately the fossil
record is still lacking all the way
around so why is that now what I think
is a possibility is that we modern
humans have been influenced from an
outside source that beings came here and
essentially combined us with either
Neanderthals or Denisovans who knows one
of those species and perhaps were a mix
of them I mean the under tall's and
Denisovans went extinct approximately
41,000 years ago and it's a mystery we
don't know why either of them went
extinct but besides our DNA similarities
between Neanderthals and Denisovans we
were also shocked to learn ins just 2016
that we cannot account for a
y-chromosome link between modern males
and Neanderthals why is that and
although that may not be evidence of
aliens intermixing with us it is
evidence that we don't know the entire
story of our ancestors and there are
some unexplained gaps in our lineage I
mean if they can find evidence of
evolution and primates why not us but
most of all there seems to be something
out of place among humans I mean we're a
bit crazy don't you think and we don't
seem to exactly fit in or appear to be
part of a natural part of this
environment because in fact we're a
plague to the planet we destroy
everything it's just something feels off
and it just doesn't make sense if all
the other animals evolved and things
worked out naturally
why are we so much different but like I
said if there is any truth to this
obviously beings would have had to have
come here that had advanced knowledge of
DNA genomes and although we know a lot
about DNA specifically the details of
the chemical process we have not figured
out the coding in its entirety and it's
actually been described as having all
the letters of a language but not
knowing what the language actually is
and in other words we do have a lot to
learn so just to clarify I am not
convinced of an alien hybrid theory in
fact there are other theories too that
are worth looking at and I'm not trying
to convince you of this theory either I
just simply think that it makes far more
sense but this theory holds more water
than some of the other explanations that
have been shared by mainstream science
and I think it's just worthy of looking
at in further discussion with an open
mind and seeking out new evidence but
too many people seem to completely shun
the possibility of aliens in any type of
conversation it's almost as if there's
this level of not wanting it to be true
that people and perhaps it could be
related to organised religions and
academics that all these teachings would
essentially be changed drastically if it
turned out that this was to be true so I
think that a lot of people are just
really uncomfortable with it but it
doesn't mean that there isn't some truth
to it in some way this reminds me of an
excellent quote by Aristotle which is it
is the mark of an educated mind to be
able to entertain a thoughts without
accepting it so obviously if any of this
is true it raises so many questions and
possibilities why did they do this why
did they come here are we part of an
experiment are they trying to spread
intelligent life throughout the galaxy
where they here to observe us and do
whatever and control us I mean who knows
there are so many unknowns things that
we just don't know but what I do know is
human behavior and if we could we would
literally be watching other
civilizations from across the galaxy
like the best reality TV show ever that
we would never get bored of I mean I
wouldn't be surprised if we're being
observed from other intelligent beings
whether it's from close or afar I mean
we have to remind ourselves that ever
since 1939 with the opening of the
Olympic Games our television waves have
been broadcasted out into space in
basically every direction at the speed
of light for 79 years now which means
that any civilization that's intelligent
79-year light-years away which is in
credibly far by the way would know about
our existence possibly now some people
instantly just blow this off and say no
space is too far it's not meant to be
traveled it's impossible but I mean look
how much we've accomplished in the last
100 years telephones cell phones
Internet's computers cars airplanes
everything else I mean what are we going
to be capable of a hundred years from
now or 500 years from now or a thousand
years from now so things that we once
thought were crazy and impossible turn
out to be true so we shouldn't just you
know say that the distance means that
this is impossible
but with all this said we need to take a
closer look at the similarities among
the different civilizations from across
the continents including the Greek gods
the Roman gods the Indian gods the
Sumerian gods and others perhaps the
various myths from across different
corners of the world all originate from
the same thing anyways guys I'm going to
close this up but leave a comment and
share your thoughts and insight on this
topic because obviously there is so much
more information that is worthy of being
mentioned in this video that I didn't
have time to fit in so there will be
other videos in the future on this topic
as well but I'm Jimmy this is bright
insight like and subscribe leave me a
comment and I have many more videos to
come soon I should have another video up
later this weekend or early next week
and of another video just a few days
after that so take care everybody